مدينه غازي عنتاب بعد الزلزال محل موصده
ومطاعم مغلقه في مدينه كانت تنبض بالحياه
العاملون فيها تائهون بينما يحاول اجلاء
اسرته وبين من يبحث عن مكان يصلح للعيش
بعد توالي الهزه
محمد واحد من هؤلاء عاش رعب ليله الزلزال
مع اسرته تنقل بين الاقامه في المساجد
وصلاه العزاء ثم استقر به المقام هنا مع
والدته واطفاله لم يفكر محمد في مشكله
اطعام اسرته فالمراكز التي اعدتها بلديه
غازي عنتاب بالتعاون مع المتطوعين وجمعيات
خيريه توزع يوميا ملايين الوجبات الساخنه
بالاضافه الى توزيع الطعام علينا يقوم
مجموعه من اهل الخير بتوزيع احتياجات
الاطفال كالحليب وغيره لكن هذا لا يمنع
وجود السلوكيات غير لائقه من البعض هنا
كالشرقه والاحتكار
جلوس كان المدينه والولايات العاشر
المتاثره بالزلزال كحال محمد باتوا
يعتمدون على الوجبات المجانيه
فقيرهم تناول طعامه وبالمجان في مظهر من
مظاهر التكافل التي ظهرت بعد الزلزال
والتي خففت من معاناه الالاف
يشرف الشيف نوح على فريق من موظفي المطعم
والمتطوعين يحرص على معايير الجوده
المعتاده وكان شيئا لم يحدث
تصلهم المواد الاوليه من جمعيات خيريه ومن
البلديه فيعدون ويقدمون مئات الالاف من
الوجبات يوميا لمحتاجيها يقدم هذا المطعم
بفروعه ومطاعم اخرى في ولايه غازي عنتاب
ملايين الوجبات
نحن مستمرون لتلبيه احتياجات المتضررين في
غاز عنتاب وقراها المحيطه نوفر الطعام
والشراب نعمل على مدار اليوم ونوفر عبر
فروعنا ملايين الوجبات للمحتاجين
تظافر جهود الحكوميه والخاصه ازاح عن
المتضررين من الزلزال اهم البحث عن الطعام
مؤقتا لكن الى متى بظل غياب افق زمني واضح
لموعد نهايه عيش المشردين في الشوارع
خصوصا في الولايات الاكثر تاثرا بالزلزال
وهو سؤال يطرحه سكان المخيمات
غازي عنتاب